hey guys what is going on welcome to
another tkinter tutorial video in the
last video what we were doing is
creating this basically the start page
and then we were running this button and
I was showing you guys how you can pass
functions through the command but if you
want to pass a function through
parameter it's a bit of a problem and so
this is how we get about a get around
that now what I want to show you guys is
actually like at let's add a page you
know so the only thing I would change
here is we're going to say lambda and
instead of this we're going to go ahead
and call a lambda : and this will be
controller dot show underscore frame and
then what frame do we want to show well
we're going to show page 1 so we're
going to say page 1 is the name of this
function so um and actually I'm sorry
that's not that's not function that's a
that's a class so um yeah so that's good
enough so now we need a page 1 so this
is how we're going to add a page and
you'll see hopefully that this is really
simple so paste our page we're going to
page 1 so now let's go ahead and we're
going to make a class page 1 it's going
to inherit from TK frame and we're going
to go ahead and do TK dot frame um oops
we forgot it in it so first we want this
to all be under in it basically the
entire page function is going to be
under in it for now there may come a
time when you don't have it under in it
for some reason but chances are you're
going to program every bit of your page
under your init function so we'll see
our init method it's a fine under so i
underscore init underscore underscore
and then as usual its self parent and
controller :
and then TK dot frame dot underscore
underscore underscore underscore um self
parent ok nothing new there
and then um let's go ahead and basically
we're just going to copy and paste this
exact same label so copy that paste that
and really we could have copied pretty
much like all of this could have been
copied and in fact we can even copy we
can take the button so let's go ahead
and copy this button format here and
then we'll just paste that same button
and instead of visit page one we'll say
a back to home and then under command
lambda show frame instead of page one
which is this one we want to run start
page okay so make sure that you've done
the copy and paste identically to mean
basically these two these two classes
right here should look nearly identical
I mean they've got a different name and
some different text to the button and
stuff and the button runs different
stuff but they should look identical to
each other pretty much so we've got
these buttons here and uh and all that
and another thing too is people might
ask you know why do you because like a
lot of people will do in tkinter which
again we'll see down the road why this
is a huge problem is you can just say
button pack and then you can you can in
fact add more buttons to the start page
like we could just do this right even
though it's the same exact button but
when we go to run this um oh what do we
do
back to home okay we never closed this
off okay we'll try again okay so you see
how we have like all these buttons here
and they're all showing up on the page
but the problem is with this tkinter
function out here the super wanting to
use lambda but if like I was saying
later on when you go to pass through
variables you're going to have a problem
because they're all corresponding to the
same object and so that becomes
problematic so eventually you'll have to
do something like this button to button
- and then button three button three
something like that so this object isn't
being redefined every time because as
long as you pack it it shows up on the
window and it'll do it's sort of
function so anyways
just keep that in the back of your mind
just in case you decide to skate from my
tutorials like a dummy so page one
TK frame so we pack the button and
that's basically uh basically it so that
will take us to uh to page one now what
do we have to do though um with page one
is we have to come up here and see if
our CTC objc app see page one exists now
but it's not loaded right so if you
remember what is show frame do so if we
come up here this is show frame it's
going to go frame equal self dot frames
and then whatever that container is that
we want and it's going to raise it to
the top well here's the kicker if it's
not in self dot frames well I'm sorry
it's not going to work so so we have to
pass a page one no different than we
passed start page through before so now
what we do is self dot frames can stay
uh stay by itself but then what we're
going to do is we're going to say for
capital F for for frame in and then now
we add a list or actually a tuple of
frames so we're gonna say for F in a
start page and page one right what do we
want to do with those well basically all
of this these three lines of code so
we're going to just tab over those three
lines so if you're not familiar you can
highlight a block of code hit tab and
it'll move it all over for you
so soft.i frames for F in start page
page one we basically run this code and
um and this is saving this basically to
self dot frames which is this dictionary
and then later on when we go to show
frame we just passed through hey I want
to show this frame and that's the frame
that's shown so now if I've got all my
ducks in a row which you know who knows
let's go ahead and run it and see if
this if this works out for us so we've
got start page I know okay uh
okay um sorry about that uh the thing
that we did is originally we just ran
for at like we just had you know the
start page right um so what we what we
have to change is like this is we're in
our for loop and so we need to make
frame equals F container self and then
self dot frames instead of star page F
okay now let's go ahead and run that one
more time oh and we need to change our
text apparently yeah it's our button
changed but our text isn't really being
clear to us so let's get call this so a
start page page one okay so now we run
that and we see okay start page and then
visit page one cool now we're on page
one back to home so that's how you can
make multiple pages and kind of navigate
between those pages so now we're going
to go ahead and do is is were let's add
one more page so since we've already got
this for loop that was really the thing
the major change that we had to make so
now let's say we want to make another
page so what we're going to do is come
down here and really basically let's
just highlight page one let's just paste
and we're going to call this page two
and then we'll call this page two we've
still got back to home and then we could
also add another button here so we can
say back to home and then copy this come
down let's call this button two and we
say uh set about to home we can say page
one right page one show frame a page one
so that's that and then here on page one
you could say back to home no problema
but then also you could have another
button we'll just copy and paste and
this one could be a page to show frame
page too easy and then on the start page
we can add so we've got page 1 let's go
ahead and copy and paste button 2 here
copy
come up here paste button 2 this is page
2 let's go ahead and keep it uniform and
say visit page 2 the rest of this can
stay um so then now what do we need to
do well we have to take a page 2 now and
we just need to add it to our list right
here
so comma page 2 let's save that see if
we can get away with this so here's our
start page Wow
get over here mirror so here's our start
page visit page 1 awesome back to home
visit page 2 cool now go to page 1 back
to home to 1 now we're at 1 let's go
back to 2 one back and forth home so now
we're able to use as you can see
navigate through our entire application
here which is really something that I
just sadly that was like one of the
hardest things I could do and that's
like obviously one of the most essential
things if you're making an application
you have to be able to go between like
windows and stuff so that was kind of
annoying that week I couldn't figure out
how to get that to work but anyway
that's how it's done so from now on all
you have to do to add a new page is you
create that that class inherit from TK
frame define in it and then basically
you don't have to have any of this code
you just have all you have to have you
have to have any of this code right and
as long as you do that and you can add
anything you want to the page and then
once you've made that class you add it
to this list up here that's it so as
promised it does get better once you
have the baseline all you got to do add
the new class add it to this this tuple
here boom done right so anyway hopefully
you guys enjoyed that I was really
excited when I figured this out I forget
who posted like there was like some
example I found on Google of someone
doing it this way and I was like I was
brilliant so I think
this needs to be on like the actual
official tkinter documentation like why
isn't it there so anyway hope you guys
enjoyed it if you for whatever reason
weren't able to keep up or you've got
any questions or comments please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time